all right let's keep taking calls here
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 it is the day of
donald trump's inauguration let's go
next to the caller in the to15 area code
who's this
hi David my name is Bryan I've been a
fan of your show for a few years right I
think maybe 2011's I run a YouTube
channel myself I've used a source a few
times so you're a great guy thank you
all right
essentially Betsy DeVos yeah I am
currently studying to become a teacher
and the more I look into her man the
more horrified I get yeah you know
looking out into public schools what
could happen to someone like me you know
I'm starting to be a special ed teacher
what this could mean for variety Ludd
soon as you know and it's just that you
know I was a special Institute so I know
what that struggles like and the idea of
public schools being even more destroyed
than they already aren't is beyond
revolting it's like I wonder if this
woman's like a social Darwinist or
something yeah well listen I mean I
share your concerns about Betsy DeVos
she you know we covered on the Wednesday
show she thinks that guns in schools
might make sense because grizzly bears
could show up she did not understand the
difference between a productivity and
growth approach and was embarrassed by
senator Al Franken when questioned about
that she was then questioned by Tim
Kaine about whether the same standard
should apply to public charter in
private schools she barely even
understood the question
it is idiocracy that officially starts
today with the inauguration of Trump and
you know what I wish I had something
positive to say to you but if you're
looking to be a public school teacher
under Betsy DeVos you're right to be
scared I don't have any words of
inspiration for you sadly other than you
can still to the extent that you'll have
funding to have a job and earn a salary
once you're in the classroom you can
hopefully do the best possible job that
you're able to do and and that's really
all you can control
well that's my hope I guess one look all
I want for my students are to be
productive members of society I am guess
question the system you know an early
age you know know the Constitution know
the Bill of Rights you know by heart so
when again the middle school they know
this cuz yeah well I don't know the Bill
of Rights might hard I don't know that
I'm not as good of an advocate for
things because I can't recite it from
memory but figuratively point taken
point taken and really really appreciate
the call and and I share your concern so
thank you so much for calling in today